- What's going on?
- [Mark] Okay, Suicidal?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So where'd you grow up?
- What you say?
- [Mark] Where'd you grow up?
- Where'd I grow up at?
- [Mark] What part of town?
I was born in the wild, though,
but I was raised in five deuce.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- I said I was born in the
wild, but I was raised in L.A.
- [Mark] Oh, okay.
And what age were you
when you entered the gang?
- My hood?
I was always in the hood.
- [Mark] But what age were you when-
- At the age of fourteen.
Five Deuce Hoover, ya hear?
- [Mark] And how old were you
when you first got involved in the gang?
- I was 14.
- [Mark] 14?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both parents, one parent?
- Nah, my mom was sick.
Ah, shit, here we go.
Nah, my pops was doing a life sentence.
He died in prison, man.
- [Mark] You were a kid?
- He left me at age two, homie.
- [Mark] Your dad died in prison?
- Yeah, age two. He left me at age two.
He died. I was 19, so.
I only saw him twice a year.
- [Mark] Mm hmm.
And your mom? What's the story as well?
Naw, she was good. She's good now.
She was a crackhead. You
know what I'm sayin'?
She's good now though.
- Oh, okay.
She go to church. She's a changed woman.
- [Mark] So the gang was
like a natural place for you.
It's my family. It's my family.
Man, it's hot.
- [Mark] It was your family.
- It always will be until I die.
- [Mark] And prison time,
have you done any prison time?
- Yeah, 15 years straight, holmes.
- [Mark] Oh, yeah?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What was that for?
- Home invasion, robbery, shit like that.
- [Mark] What age was that?
- When I was 18.
- [Mark] 18?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Did you finish
high school at all?
Nah, I left after 11th grade.
At 11th grade, I left.
- [Mark] Oh, at 11th grade?
- I caught a charge, so I couldn't finish.
You know what I'm sayin'?
- [Mark] Right.
- I got my GED, though.
- [Mark] Oh, good.
- Yeah, I got my GED.
I got prison, but I got my GED. (chuckles)
Yeah, I had to get that.
I can say one thing,
you know what I'm sayin'?
- [Mark] Yes.
- I'm glad, you know?
- [Mark] That's pretty hard
on pretty much everyone
in these situations.
- Yeah.
It's hot.
- [Mark] But you still have
contact with your family?
- My mom, yeah. Hell, yeah, I love my mom.
I love my mom, ya know what I mean?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I love my mom, always, you know?
No matter what she did,
she was always by me.
You know what I mean?
She was always by me.
Ya know what I'm sayin'?
But it was hard, you know?
Especially growing up. Nobody was there.
Ya feel me?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Very hard, ya know.
It's still hard, but I live
and die in L.A. (chuckles)
- [Mark] Yeah, you've seen
some crazy stuff being
in the gang, right?
Lost friends, stuff like that?
- To see crazy stuff, you
don't have to be in a gang.
You see crazy stuff everywhere
you go. The world's crazy.
Ya know what I'm sayin'?
You don't got to be in a gang to be crazy.
Ya know what I'm saying?
Well, it's just that in a gang,
you recognize craziness.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- That's all. You recognize it.
- [Mark] What personality traits
do you think a person needs
to survive in a gang?
- Just be real, man.
Just be real. Be you, be you.
That's all. Be you.
Ya know what I'm saying? Don't be fake.
Don't try to pretend to be somebody else.
You get more respect.
You live longer just being you.
That's all.
That's what it's all about, ya know?
Not to get caught up.
Everybody wanna be like their super...
The movie shit. Ya know what I'm saying?
Nah, it aint about that. It's
about survival, that's all.
That's all it's about, survival.
Take your own. That's all it's about.
Ya know what I mean?
Just be able to survive.
If you don't survive, you get run over.
Just not by gangs;
by anybody, police,
anybody could get run over.
Ya know? That's what it's about?
- [Mark] So when you were in
your twenties, teens, whatever-
- My twenties. I didn't see no twenties.
My whole twenties, I was in prison.
I didn't see not one day in my twenties.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
- Yeah, I never saw one day.
Never seen one day in
my twenties, ya hear?
All I saw was bars and gates.
- [Mark] All of your twenties,
you were still in prison?
- All the twenties, all
I saw was bars and gates.
Ching, ching.
- [Mark] Well, obviously, gang life
in prison still exists.
It's just different here.
- This is a world inside a world.
That's all it is. Ya feel me?
Anything that goes
outside, you do it inside.
Well, the guards is gangsters...
Nine out of ten, the
guards is more gangsters
than the inmates. (chuckles)
Ya feel me?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- That's how it is.
For real. (chuckles)
- [Mark] Tell us some stories
about some of the violence you
saw when you were in prison.
You saw some crazy stuff, I'm sure.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a lot of crazy shit.
There's a lot of crazy
shit, though, ya know?
It is what it is. (chuckles)
It is what it is.
- [Mark] Do you feel safer
being out of prison than in?
- Shit! (chuckles)
That's a good question. ( chuckles)
A damn good question. (chuckles)
That's a good question, man.
Do I feel safer out here
than in prison? (laughs)
I'll tell you one thing, in prison,
it's that question there,
it's why I'm laughing at that
cause in prison, you know what to expect.
You wake up, you gotta tie your shoes,
you know what you gotta do,
but out here, you don't
know what to expect.
The closer ones be the dangerous ones.
Ya know what I mean?
The protectors of the
city are more dangerous
than the criminals, I guess.
So how do I put this?
You go to the grocery
store, you get locked up.
Or so just cops who don't like me,
they throw shit on me.
So safe? (chuckles)
- [Mark] When were you last in prison?
- What's that?
- [Mark] How long has it been
since you were in prison?
- You mean my term or
just going to prison?
- [Mark] When was the
last time you were...
When did you get out?
- My term, at age 33, but
I did time after that.
Ya know what I'm sayin'?
But a long term, like a
year here, and two there.
Ya know what I'm sayin'?
Between 14 years old, man,
the God honest truth,
I've probably saw like
three years on the streets.
- [Mark] Only 3 years?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Since you were 14?
- I'm about to be 39.
- [Mark] Jesus.
- Maybe three years.
- [Mark] And how old are you now?
- I'll be 39.
- [Mark] 39?
- I only say three
years, about three years.
Yes, I only saw three
years. Word. (laughs)
- [Mark] So do you have kids of your own?
- No, I haven't had a chance for that yet.
- [Mark] You never had a
chance. You were in prison.
- I'm glad though. I'd be a
fucked up daddy. (chuckles)
- [Mark] Yeah. What do you
see for yourself in the next-
- Right now, though?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I ask myself...
recognizing the truth,
that that's why I slowed down, man.
Ya feeling me? Like I'm more mature now.
I might still have the
same attitude a little bit,
but as in gentleness, I'm there.
As in understanding of society
giving a chance to help you,
I'm starting to see that.
I go to church sometimes.
Ya know what I'm saying?
I can't do it by myself. I can't. I can't.
I tried, I can't.
I ain't gonna lie,
sometimes you'll catch me
or someone reaching out to me, ya know?
Getting a little help
sometimes, and I listen.
But it's hard to really listen
and try to follow what
you listening cause...
At least, I got to church Sunday.
I'm coming out. It's wartime.
You feel me? (chuckles)
You know what I'm sayin'?
You can't go out on the streets and say,
"God save when shit's going down."
- [Mark] Right.
- It is what it is. It is what it is.
- [Mark] And where are you staying now?
Where do you live now?
- On the streets, skid row.
- [Mark] Oh, (indistinct)
- Skid row.
- [Mark] Are you still active in the gang?
- Until I die. Until I die.
- [Mark] (indistinct)
- Why not? At least, somebody love me.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So if you get called on to do out
to do whatever you need
to do for the gang,
you're there.
- I can't say that. I
ain't gonna gang bang.
I ain't dumb. I'm getting to old for that.
When I say as in, but as in loving,
giving them advices.
You feel me? I don't know. (mumbling)
I'm not in for that. I'd be a damn fool.
I'm too old for that. I
don't got time for that.
I did mean, but yeah, I'm still active,
as in they're still my family.
They're still my nephews,
you know what I mean?
- [Mark] Right.
- Somebody gotta lead them
or teach them the right way.
If I don't do it, then who will?
So I mean, active, you would say, yeah,
but as in doing gang shit?
No. Hell, no.
I'm not a coward, man.
Bloods is my friends too.
Ya know what I'm saying?
Friends to me, do ya know what I meant?
I look at it as in, "Why kill each other?"
Ya know what I mean?
- [Mark] Do you have regrets about-
- Hell, yeah! You don't even
have to finish that. (laughs)
- [Mark] It goes without saying?
- Yeah, a lot of regrets,
man. A lot of regrets.
I'd take shit back. I wish I could.
I wish I could.
I made a lot of dumb choices.
I understand that what they doing now is
what I used to do,
so I'd be a hypocrite
saying they're doing wrong.
I was doing the same shit,
you know what I'm sayin'?
Hard-headed, no father,
so it's like, I couldn't
tell no gangsters,
"You, what you're doing is wrong."
Nah, they gotta learn it their way.
Learning is about experience, right?
That's the way you learn.
Especially if you don't have no real,
hard father figure in your life.
- [Mark] It is, it's...
- It's very hard, man. (indistinct)
And people out there shouldn't judge us
because we didn't get the chance.
I didn't get that chance.
You know what I'm sayin'?
You can't judge me. I
didn't get that chance
to have a father figure to
tell me what's right or wrong.
I didn't, so how are you gonna
judge me and say I'm bad.
That's my life.
- [Mark] Yeah, it wasn't your fault.
- People out there, they be hypocrites.
They say that. I was a young
boy with no leadership.
So how you gonna say that I
should be locked up forever.
That'd be wrong. Y'all
ain't God saying that.
God wouldn't say that. That's all.
God wouldn't say that.
If I had a chance,
maybe I would've been in a better society.
I was a young kid.
I would've been better,
but I didn't have a chance.
Never. Going to school, getting jumped.
Coming home, getting jumped.
How do you have a chance?
You gotta got to school, right?
So I need a chance.
- [Mark] All right, thank you
so much for talking to me.
- No doubt.
- [Mark] I appreciate it.